δεν πρέπε αποϊδεύσεις όλον αυτό να μόμε μος εψήφηση μεγάλη ευθύνει το μεγαλο πόοςουδεν είναι
εφυσυχασμος τιθέτος για μνα η χειρότερο πράγμα που πράε πι κάποιο είνα ότι μετάκιος απόσεψήη
νέα έργα νέα ξεενοδοχία στον τουρισμόν πλέον για αριθμή δείχρουν ότι είμαστε νονούμετρία προρισμός τουριστών
στην κύπρον αυτό ία ν η μελέτς πέρσι θέλεις να είσαι εποψηφιο τοπο ετό κτον
πολέίο πάντοότε είναι ότι κοσοτσες η πολος που θελο νός καια ήταν η πιο δυσκολη
περίοδος που αντιμετώπηση ένο αντρέας βύρας στη θέση του δημάρκου λάρναν έξει τονα βάγειον του
λιμανιού μαρίνας ήταν να περίοδος πολλά έτσ έντονί και και δυσκολή και προκλοηγήπριος τη πήματα
κάτωαπό την μέσυνεδεκτηκα νο αντρέας στην πολιτική δεκτησητιγμα τα κάτο πό ην μέση εγίνεται ο
αντρέας βίρα θέλει να αχηση την πόλη του ταν φύγει από την καρέκλατου δημάνα επερπανουμε
στη πολη χήακλέ μου πάνου ζόικατου και εγαλεί ο κόσμος τούλος ο άνθρωπος πρόσφερε μέται
πράγμαθεκπολλες γιαγελι άλλο έναντ ένα λλα ευπότκα σήμερα μαζί σας εδώ για να συζητήσουμε τα
διστοπικής αυτό οδήγήσης και όχι μόνο ο δήμαρχος λάρνακας και πρόεδρος της ενόσις δήμονο κύριος
αντρέας βρας κυριπρ σας χαιρετό και ευχαριστώπαμε δεκτεία την πρόσκληση μου χαράμου ώ ευχαριστώγια η
πρόσκληση ξεκινούμε από την ερώτηση τη βασική κατεμένα σε όλος τους σκαλεσμένους ποιος είνο αντριαβύραςάξ
ο αντρέας ο πήρας τουλάχιστον αυτό που θέλω να πω είναι ότι δεν άλλα ξεν
όταν έγινε δήμαρχος θέρω νανα πω θεωρώ του ράχιστουν ότι όπως ήταν ο αντρας οπίρας
έμεινε ο αντρές ο ύρας ένας άνθρωπος ο οποίος πάντα έείχει ενένια τα εκινά και
ανας άνθρωπος ο οποίος χωρίς πολλά λόγιαδουλιά τουλάχι στον πάρουμε και να πεδίγο τους στόχους
που αναλάβαμε τρχιστον